fans agree Captain America civil war is
one of the best superhero movies ever
made but just because it's awesome
doesn't mean it's perfect we're more
than willing to forgive Marvel their few
mistakes but in the spirit of
constructive criticism here is a look at
some of the dumb things in Captain
America Civil War that everyone just
ignored Tony Stark's terrible phone
product placement in big movies is
inescapable these days but this is pure
marketing shenanigans run amok in the
first Iron Man film stark used what was
at the time the most cutting-edge phone
around the LG VX 9400 Ironman ability LG
ingenuity together in every LG phone in
Ironman - he got a slate a sci-fi glass
branded with LG in stark tech logos but
in civil war it's a vivo v3 a fairly
cheap phone mainly available in Asia the
move was done for product placement for
when the movie showed in that market but
for a tech billionaire like Stark it
just seems silly he should be using
something so cool we can't even imagine
it not something anyone could pick up at
a corner shop that security camera on a
nowhere back road back I helmet Zemo has
a sinister plan that revolves around
grainy security footage of the Winter
Soldier killing Tony Stark's parents so
two big questions here why is there a
security camera on a random deserted
backwoods road and how on earth did the
footage survive the present day
considering Winter Soldier shoots out
the camera when he's done it's an
amazing coincidence beyond belief that
there just happened to be a security
camera on a tree right where Howard
Starks car crashed unless that's the
winter soldiers lucky killing tree how
they make that Spidey suit so fast Tony
Stark convinces spider-man to join his
cause in part with the promise of
building him up a high-tech new costume
you're in dire need of an upgrade
systemic top-to-bottom 100-point
restoration that's why I'm here just a
few hours later
Spidey shows up already wearing the
completed suit that was fast
as Tony secretly been working on a
spider-man suit and a spare time all
along maybe Tony's hobby is designing
clothes for all of his buddies that
would explain the vision sweaters anyway
that schemes not what it seems
zimos big plan to cause The Avengers to
destroy themselves works amazing
well especially considering it doesn't
actually make any sense and relies
entirely on coincidence
an empire toppled by its enemies can
rise again but one which crumbles from
within that's dead for starters there's
that unexplained tree base security
camera footage we mentioned earlier but
that's just the start what about the
fact that the big showdown at the end of
the film only works if Iron Man happens
to follow Captain America to the bunker
that something Zemo couldn't possibly
have known would happen if Iron Man had
stayed put the end of the movie would
have just been kept kicking zimos butt
and then stopping the incriminating
video tape into pieces an even bigger
coincidence his plan is designed to
cause the Avengers to fight amongst
themselves but by the time his plan
starts they're already fighting with
each other over the sokovia accords
sometimes I want to punch you in your
perfect teeth which means his whole plan
is kind of pointless
especially since he could have
accomplished everything he wanted by
simply emailing video Tony Stark instead
of trying to trick him into flying all
the way to Siberia to view it on a VHS
tape hey Tony could have just watched a
video on a vivo smartphone whatever
happened to that doomsday virus the
movie begins with a breathless action
sequence as the Avengers tried to stop
the villain crossbones from stealing a
deadly biological weapon just dis
Captain America is about to learn who's
behind the theft crossbones blows
himself up and then everyone gets so
busy making speeches they forget to
wonder who was hiring super villains to
steal a doomsday virus and more
importantly why was it Simo or maybe the
ghost of Robert Redford or was Ultron up
to his old tricks again maybe we'll
learn the answer when everyone suddenly
turns into zombies and Avengers 3 where
were Nick Fury and shield Nick Fury was
basically the architect of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and played a
significant role in just about every big
event within the MCU well at least he
did because you think he might have
something to say about the events of
Civil War yet he was completely and
mysteriously absent from the film get me
off the grid also missing Giri
second-in-command Maria Hill who we last
saw helping train the new super team at
the end of age of Ultron so what the
heck happened to her and then there's
the total absence of shield which has
been going strong on television even as
the movies continue to conspicuously
ignore their existence given the
shield's whole mission at the beginning
of the MCU is to provide oversight
superhero activities it would make sense
for them to be at least a little
involved with the sokovia accords but
apparently shield Nick Fury and Maria
Hill were all busy taking a long
vacation in Tahiti we should go sometime
where tahini it's a magical place
flip-floppers between Tony Stark's
creation Ultron blowing up sokovia in
Avengers age of Ultron and the Scarlet
Witch taking out a part of a building in
civil war the Avengers sure have a lot
to answer for but not to the government
remember this is the same government
that tried to nuke New York City and
Avengers I've got a nuke coming in its
gonna blow in less than a minute
it's beyond hypocritical for the
government to get upset at the Avengers
for causing collateral damage when they
were planning to kill literally millions
of their own citizens stop some aliens
the recruits don't fit when it's time
for the big showdown Captain America and
Iron Man go on recruiting missions but
the folks they end up with don't really
make sense in ant-man Scott Lang spends
the whole film trying to go straight
leaving the criminal life behind so he
could be a good dad to his daughter that
goes out the window with no explanation
as ant-man becomes a fugitive again
pretty much because he has a man crush
on Chris Evans which fair enough ah this
is awesome
Captain America I know you too you're
great
jeez and that goes double for Hawkeye
who actually retired at the end of
Avengers 2 to spend time with his wife
and family only to end up in a secret
prison in the middle of the ocean
because well we don't know why because
it's never addressed hey Clint a man
clearly retirement doesn't suit you you
got tired of shooting golf well I played
18 shot 18 this Gannon seemed amiss
meanwhile on the other side Tony Stark
goes ahead and recruits a nerdy high
school kid and throws him into combat
against Captain freaking America not to
mention the Winter Soldier the deadliest
assassin the world has ever known you
have a metal arm that is awesome dude
that's just negligent and they would
never be cool with that Tony that's a
straight-up deal-breaker dude thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel and
watch more videos like the one you just
saw and don't forget to check out all
this cool stuff we know you'll love to